plus nécessaire d'envoyer sa candidature
pour se défier sous les couleurs des
tribus jaune ou rouge un espace de jeu
koh lanta inaugurée dans le parc france
miniature par l'une des figures
emblématiques de la célèbre émission
clémence castel cet univers on retrouve
l'univers koh lanta évidemment et toutes
les épreuves qui vont avec il ya une
épreuve de chasse au trésor c'est un
milieu très très aquatique donc
forcément dans koh lanta on retrouve de
l'eau que ce soit sur les plages ou même
par la pluie malheureusement parfois
petits et grands pourront traverser les
bambous dans le but d'en sortir le moins
30 est possible jusqu'à l'affrontement
final sur la mythique épreuve des
poteaux pour tous les les fans de
l'émission ben voilà ils vont retrouver
tout tout ce qui entoure et tout ce qui
fait rêver dans koh lanta c'est à dire
laventure le dépassement de soi et je
suis sûr que tous les familles vont
passer un très bon moment dans cet
univers un espace pensé avec alp la
société de production de koh lanta l'a
fallu à peu près un nom en termes de
conception entre la la réflexion et la
l'inauguration il avait déjà travaillé
ensemble sur le précédent lieu
thématique du park l'antre du père
fouras du fort boyard inauguré en 2010
est
notre constance c'est de garder des
marqueurs qui sont pour les familles ce
soit à partager entre enfants
transgénérationnel ça c'est notre marque
heures et qui soit un côté ludique et
pédagogique mais en tout cas on veut
qu'ils aient des sensations des émotions
du partage il faudra donc compter sur ce
détour des paysans pour visiter le parc
117 monument à petite échelle car sa
présence est irrévocable